so let's talk about the makeup that you
actually used
to conceal these injuries on her face on
december 16th
i believe you testified you used a
concealer with a peach undertone
did you have training and experience um
dealing with injuries or covering up
bruising on people do you have any
specific experience for education
specific experience i have experience in
doing bruises and cover bruises for
special effect
i mean throughout my career i have
created bruises and i also have covered
bruises
for you know with models or
real life things whatever it is so yeah
i i have experience in covering some
bruises yes
how about swelling same question
i mean it's really it's a little harder
to cover swelling
that would be maybe you know
try to bring the swelling down covering
covering it up would be not great would
be harder
and how about cuts
yeah
specifically as it relates to ms heard's
makeup look on december 16th do you
recall what
foundation you used
the brand
you probably don't remember the brand
but do you recall the shade that you
how would i no it's five years ago
absolutely not
okay
but you do have a specific recollection
of using a peach undertone concealer
yes and i tell you why because amber
always had in her bag we have the same
concealer she has a concealer from a
brand called clear pool
and it's a specific
shade uh you know it's beige beige was
amber's color for under eyes
period so the day december 16
i did a news beige i use
there's another concealer that has a
little more peach in there and orange
it's
it's called honey from the same family
and i use that instead
and i think i also use i have a wheel
that has is a bruised wheel that has
different colors and you pick up the
color to
gently touch up any darkness
did you make a different choice for her
overall look other than the concealer as
a result of the injuries that you saw on
her face on december 16th not a
different choice but i remember we
specifically
you know
as you i know you read it before she we
we had a red lip it was not uncommon for
her we know she has a signature red lip
so it's not suddenly it was oh my gosh
has a red lip but i remember that day
specifically
i specifically structured my makeup
there's a couple of things we do with
amber we do a smoky eye and a nude lip
or red lip and i remember specifically
thinking of my makeup about we needed to
highlight
there to try to
not to try to not draw attention there
and the reddit was our only option to
cover that red
cut that was there so that i remember
very specifically thinking that we had
we had to have a red lip
sharp brows and construct the makeup to
take away
from here so basically i mean it's not
going to be nothing to you guys but just
basically a lot of highlight up here to
kind of
not focus on this i remember talking
about it very clearly
and
forgive my ignorance
but what did you do to cover up the cut
on the lip other than apply a red lip
a red lip
okay
a red lip uh it is swollen
i can see it in a video on the james
bond show so a lips was swollen it was
bigger on that side you can see it
there's nothing i can do about that but
i did we did a really dark red lip too
to match that red
gas should cut whatever that was there